what's the first thing you've done but
those of you who have actually got the
past diverted your acne what's the first
thing you've got a bit to help you with
getting a picture and yesterday okay so
you got a plant relation namely X X plus
2 and X plus 3 right now think back to
last week I know it's been a while you
have any bass lessons exist in one of my
things about the requests but one of the
reasons why we factorize sang x remember
I gave you a big faces last week and I
said factorization is not just a process
you do because you can it reveals
something about the object you're
looking at it reveals something about
the structure of a number or the
structure of some how to rate expression
you've got so you factorize down what
does that reveal to you about the
structure of this object what can you
see here more obviously when you can see
yeah I asked before on a graph one of
the important things you're going to
need to include on your graph of the
answers you supplied me was the
intercept right the intercepts
now this form TRR shows us those
intercepts well these will show some of
which integers does this show
this shows us the X intercepts because
it's factorizing it turns off by the way
if you want to get the y intercept you
just look at this this form is already
ready for the why is that do you see
that look there is right there how do
you get the widest sense on anything
what do you do you let X equal 0 right
which get rid of all of the terms leave
you do just with the sticks are you
happy with that
so I can see then you 2 day 3 let's try
to do a reasonable scale Europe all call
that bigger 2 is negative 3 I could go
ahead and I control where 6 is a coin
to the same scale but I'm going to cheat
a little bit and point out to you the
horror little actually needs to be
scaled internally vertical axis between
scale internally but they don't have
been scale with each other right like
this could be one unit horizontally but
don't you have to want you to vertically
okay you Scipio about you get cut that
you should do that
give it when I would know present in
person
so therefore what I'm going to do though
just going to draw through here make
sure I keep the and then wherever I need
to send to the wax I'm just going to
make that six
bye guys so here's my picture there you
go
so rather than try and say oh six should
be TR and they train like wave around my
proud a lot so that it get at that point
I'm just going to draw the nicest sort
of curve that like to do and then just
say okay this you okay right we have a
look at the next couple building it's a
bit quicker
what's the factorization of number two
we do this down
yeah excited 3 and X 2 thanks said
shares of the rich from the previous one
so if I try and make this scale
reasonable we'll call this negative over
here and now I'm going to go 1 2 3 over
there so now when I draw I'm not there
to flick it by the way just going to be
back to this guy over here did you
notice parabolas are all symmetrical
right perfectly symmetrical Florida Lee
right which is why you can draw in an
axis of symmetry if you wanted to so
when you have a look at this guy here
right the axis of symmetry where is the
axis of symmetry where would it be
it's going to be so I'm gonna be halfway
between these two spots right you see
that's incision be halfway out or it in
actually will be halfway between these
two so will you have a look at this in
the axis of symmetry identity of this
silo Y axis or on that side give it to
the right is it just a little bit ok the
reason that's important is because when
I draw my grammar I want to make sure I
get the vertex that motor part in the
right position ok so I'm going to do
something roughly like
do you think my absence initiations just
off to the right by vertex is just off
to the right it would be a problem if we
drew on the axis or to the left it
wouldn't be symmetrical anymore what is
my name again you can tell me just by
looking at it in the original form very
good ok now this last one is the little
problematic because you get a factorize
and what happens what would you do with
this yeah okay so you can put it into
what let's rewind a little bit the
reason why my tea can go into the
formula is because you can't think of a
pair of numbers that add to and
multiplies to for coming by I'm really
going silver so you're in trouble just
50 pairs of numbers like we could here
so that more you naturally you go
towards the formula okay but it should
go to the formula and something else
occurs which is take it okay so in the
scheme of numbers that we're working
with you don't get any solutions right
I'll come to this idea later on what
actual solution to get now if you go to
the pro telephone line I can mask
phylidia if you go to the quadratic
formula if you get no solutions out of
it
at least the solutions that I can graph
what did that be well that mean so my
graph word is again
yeah very good you can't get a solution
for X we mean it never collides with the
x-axis of slowly somewhere up above here
okay now remember I said to you the
factorization revealed the structure
behind an object okay so there are lots
of ways to factorize things because
there's lots of different structures to
objects so let me show you how we would
go about this I'm going to show you in a
quick version I'm not going to go
through the details because your we
can't do this in a comic called Marcus
and parabola next year but I will show
you what I actually do actually play
exactly why I do it I'm going to write
this first like so do you agree that
four is one cluster
okay I'm not anything human okay this
sound the way you say things what you
canceling what island up with is that
right it's just factor into different
way okay
so first I'm going to take that plus
three and let us subtract three from
both sides so the right length now that
looks like it's a bit pointless but stay
with me when I look at the right-hand
side having subtracted three one of my
left rear what is that you recognize
that don't you that's a by far so here's
a perfect square it's the square of one
okay now this is fatter ah it's
factorized in a different way I
certainly not what we're used to over
here we just have a y equals on the left
hand side but it's not trans in a way
which is useful to me because I can read
off of this that this vertex point that
I've been looking for that I've been
referred to is right on the axis of
symmetry
I could read off this that the vertex is
going to be a negative one it's going to
be there do you see how I can see that
you see where that comes from
I'm looking for the point that make this
zero and the point of X is here I should
head to cord okay so the x coordinate x
is 0 Y is negative 1 the y coordinate
that makes this 0 is 3 so that gives you
look for water and then I control my
parabola like that
what's this point very like looking at
original line it's just going to be 4 so
that's that